-Performing their new song,
"Officially Christmas,"
give it up for Dan + Shay!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Everybody's
starting to feel it ♪
♪ Starting to feel it
in the air ♪
-♪ All of the sidewalks,
all of the streetlights ♪
♪ Holiday magic everywhere ♪
-♪ Ooh, ooh-ooh ♪
-♪ Then it hits me ♪
-♪ It's officially Christmas ♪
♪ And I'm officially yours ♪
♪ I'm officially wishing ♪
♪ For something not in a store ♪
♪ It's already December ♪
♪ The snow's falling, too ♪
♪ Then all of a sudden,
it's true ♪
♪ It's officially Christmas ♪
♪ Now that I'm with you ♪
-♪ Ooh, ooh-ooh ♪
♪ Ooh, ooh-ooh ♪
-♪ Waiting for Santa
here by the fire ♪
♪ Listen for footsteps
on the roof ♪
♪ "Jingle Bell" rocking
over the speakers ♪
♪ Singing along
just like we do ♪
-♪ Ooh, ooh-ooh ♪
-♪ Then it hits me ♪
-♪ It's officially Christmas ♪
♪ And I'm officially yours ♪
♪ I'm officially wishing ♪
♪ For something not in a store ♪
♪ It's already December ♪
♪ The snow's falling, too ♪
♪ Then all of a sudden,
it's true ♪
♪ It's officially Christmas ♪
♪ Now that I'm with you ♪
-♪ Ooh, ooh-ooh ♪
♪ Ooh, ooh-ooh ♪
-♪ We've been counting down
the days all year ♪
♪ Raise a glass,
it's finally here ♪
♪ Ohh-ohh-ohh, ohh-ohh ♪
♪ It's officially Christmas ♪
♪ And I'm officially yours ♪
♪ I'm officially wishing ♪
♪ For something not in a store ♪
♪ It's already December ♪
♪ The snow's falling, too ♪
♪ Then all of a sudden,
it's true ♪
♪ It's officially Christmas ♪
♪ Now that I'm with you ♪
-♪ Ooh, ooh-ooh ♪
-♪ Now that I'm with you ♪
-♪ Ooh-ooh-ooh-ooh-ooh ♪
-♪ Ooh-ooh, yeah ♪
-♪ Now that I'm with you ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]